look
[Applause]
mankind and the elements
for some
it's an uncomfortable bond we can just
be taken out at any time no doubt about
it for others when weather strikes
inspiration begins dude this is it this
is it right here if they get a wave
these are the people who challenge
nature
seek out its limits
reveal its secrets
and embrace its awesome power
in this episode we'll meet an explorer
scaling peaks in the most remote edges
of the world to go where no one has gone
before if i make a mistake on this climb
or on this expedition i die
an artist who created the world's first
underwater museum to give struggling
marine life a new home you can't get a
better co-collaborator than nature and a
surf photographer who battled violent
conditions and near constant darkness in
search of the perfect image
these pioneers of the great outdoors
ahead and that's amazing
[Music]
adventure photographer chris burkhard is
an expert in photographing surfers
riding the coldest most punishing waves
on the planet
he's accustomed to battling the elements
in his work but one storm in iceland
nearly broke him
it was like armageddon we had basically
just been you know totally beaten to
shreds i mean it was total darkness
the storm canceled burkhard's expedition
but the decision to stay in iceland
resulted in a once-in-a-lifetime
photographic opportunity that he never
expected dude this is it this is it
right here
he managed to capture an epic adventure
under the greatest light show on earth
if you look at the northern lights and
you don't question your place in the
world
then there's something dead inside you i
can't believe that it's heaven
i grew up kind of frolicking along the
coast here in central california i would
drive up the coast and try to surf with
my friends and these remote little
beaches and stuff and to be honest like
that really set the president for me
that like i wanted to just go explore
i first picked up a camera
right around the age of i think 18 19.
i realized this was it this was like the
perfect medium for expression like this
was as good as it could get
when i grew up i didn't have a passport
never traveled internationally and as i
realized that photography could be this
tool to see the world i was like oh my
gosh like this this is it this could be
my ticket
after years of photographing and
stunning beach towns around the world
burkhard decided to shift his focus to
colder climates
i had the dream job and then i realized
that i want to
document places that might not be around
forever i want to share the experience
of of the importance of seeing these
places because i want people to know
that these places are out there
[Music]
there's been a lot of zero degree days a
lot of days where you're standing on the
beach or shooting somewhere on a
mountainside and you're just your organs
are hurting because it's so cold and
you're touching metal equipment and your
hands are just getting brittle and
cracked
it's type 2 fun you know you look back
and you chuckle but in the moment it's
pretty brutal you want to be somewhere
else
my work has taken me to some of the
harshest environments on the planet i
seek out some of the last places on
earth where you can really find these
raw environments
[Music]
of all the places he's been
one trip to iceland pushed him closest
to his breaking point
what started off as a trip to photograph
epic waves
became an epic battle with the elements
this last winter during the darkest and
coldest time of year we set out to
iceland
i didn't really have any idea of how it
would go
there was this one location
in this remote national park that i
wanted to go access
all i knew is that there was a boat
captain that was willing to take us
there
we finally made it to that remote bay
this national park
we're sitting there in the boat and
we're looking at this this wave
it was everything we had hoped for
the captain came out and said that the
largest storm in 25 years was coming
right now and we literally had to turn
and hightail out of there
back to the harbor
the weather changed like that and it was
like armageddon people were just like
getting food storage and stocking up
all the flights were grounded so we made
this decision that we were going to
drive 11 hours to the next safe town so
we don't come home empty-handed we were
all just defeated but still knew there
was like something else out there for us
and we just knew that we wanted to play
it out
that was probably not the smartest call
we weren't what we originally planned we
were like forced to stay a little bit
longer and after that storm subsided we
realized that with that storm brought
incredible surf and not only that but
the northern lights were out if the
weather could just hold off for that
much longer this would be something that
would be in the history books
[Music]
i convinced one of the guys to go out
the hardest thing was just keeping my
focus what i was seeing you know was
these
amazing patterns of blue and orange and
red
and green you know trickling the sky
this is maybe one of the most insane
things i've ever seen in my life
so every so often i'd get lost just
staring at the sky and somebody would
holler and i would look and see them and
be like okay okay here it is
there we go ben someone's going
you're shivering you're sitting there
you're kind of like basically going
through all the emotions but for me
anything worth pursuing is going to
require you to suffer a little bit
oh we did it
i can't believe
through all that we came away with this
experience that was actually far better
than anything we could have ever planned
for
it changed everything i thought about
what was possible
[Music]
i
aim nothing more than to simply just
document the beauty of the world
if a photograph that somebody sees is
powerful enough to make them go
somewhere they've never been
be outside of their comfort zone spend
their time that's what i speak to is
like how we can do that more
i guess we want to just inspire our
future generations to be willing to
thrust themselves into situations like
that be willing to go when everything
else says not to
even when all the odds are stacked
against you you can still create
something beautiful
[Music]
every day whenever i hear that buzzer it
just gets your blood flowing your heart
pumping and you just take off at a
sprint
you really don't know what you're
getting into um so you can see the fire
you're jumping out of a plane that's
always going to induce a little bit of
adrenaline
[Music]
there are few professions that captivate
us like smoke jumping and this is a
woman who's been doing it for over a
decade
my name is ramona biyuka and i am a
macaulay smokejumper in mccall idaho the
job of a firefighter is dangerous
but jumping out of a plane to contain a
blaze takes this job to a whole new
level there's always a possibility that
something could go wrong so they
definitely still get nervous we find the
twin otter with the door off we're all
wearing earplugs and everyone's kind of
in their own world at that point and
this fly can take up to a few hours but
it becomes clear when the danger is
close
usually you smell that smoke since that
tiny wood burning smell you know that's
go time
you get in the door
and your heart is pounding and
i don't even really think about it i
just go out of the plane
i try not to look at the ground or the
fire at that point
you're just super focused
now they fight the fire and despite the
risks it's a job ramona loves doing
i've been to so many forest fires and
every jump is different it is extremely
dynamic out there
that adrenaline is something that that's
a big part of keeping me coming back
i do stop and think wow i am really
lucky to be in this job
[Music]
high in the mountains of ecuador one man
is continuing the 500 year old tradition
of harvesting glacial ice
[Music]
reaching the top of mount chimborazo by
foot is a treacherous all-day journey
it is not for the faint of heart
and although the demand for glacial ice
is dwindling
73 year old balthazar oscar tenosaka
refuses to call it quits
foreign
chimborazo is a dormant volcano in
ecuador
is higher than mount everest if measured
from the center of the air
the traditional harvest in the eyes in
this region began with the spanish
during the colonial times they will send
the native people to retrieve the ice to
use it to make ice cream to cool the
drinks and even to keep meat fresh
[Music]
20 30 years ago there were still many
people for going up
every day of the week bringing the ice
to the lowlands now baltazar is the last
one because people make their own eyes
or they buy the ice from the ice
factories
but balthazar continues to work
because glacial ice is unique
[Music]
[Music]
that this was something very very
special it was something that you don't
see in any other place
to do physical work at that altitude
it's amazing it's amazing that that
makes of balthazar's work i think one of
the hardest works in earth really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
quite them
we call chimborazo taita chimborazo
which is father chimborazo and being the
highest volcano in ecuador you know we
have a lot of respect and love for
chimborazo
in the nearly 60 years balthazar has
been harvesting ice conditions in the
region have changed dramatically due to
climate change
[Music]
it has become warmer
the glaciers are receding at the rate of
20 to 30 meters a year the conditions
around
the ice mine are very harsh he works
right on the big rocks with the melting
of the eyes those rocks get loose and
they roll down so yeah there are danger
of avalanches
as he grows older i worry for valtter's
area
but balthazar does not worry his only
concern is delivering ice to his
remaining few vendors in the rio bamba
market
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
m
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
during the annual crab migration
all of christmas island is seeing red
[Music]
christmas island located in the pacific
ocean near australia is known for its
warm tropical climate
throughout most of the year
its endemic red crabs can be found on
the rain forest floor
but each year in late october the adult
crabs begin a spectacular mass migration
from the rainforest to the coast to
breed and release eggs into the sea
this synchronized breeding of about 40
million crabs
takes over the tiny island
they take their cues from a unique
combination of weather and the movement
of the moon
as the rains of the monsoon wet season
return
they begin their journey
the crabs arrive at the coast where they
dig burrows for mating
and then the females release their eggs
into the sea
just as the high tide from the new moon
hits the shore
these crabs are so reliant on these
seasonal cues that if the wet season
doesn't arrive on time
the crabs will not spawn until the next
lunar month
they make their migrations without much
care for road rules or streets which
results in incredible and slightly
startling waves of red crabs moving
across the island
in some of the world's coldest climates
teams of men and women don helmets eye
protection and warm clothes and head out
into the snowy terrain
to prepare for a battle against the
elements
and each other
what is this form of frigid weather
fighting you ask
they call it yukigasan
yugi means snow gas and is ball that's
why we are here now
established in 1988 as a way to
encourage tourism to japan in the winter
months
what was once a kid's game is now a
hardcore sport played in eight countries
they give us a present this is yogica
we are now here in kemi arevi in arctic
circle because we are so not we have
snow and we can could play yugi question
every day or every weekend kimmy yarvey
is famous for holding the european
yukigasu tournament each year
it is here that three japanese players
have flown in for a scrimmage
against three local finnish yukigasan
players
they have one snowball each hand and
referee visit they start and they try to
hit yukigasan is a best of three rounds
game players who are hit by a single
snowball are out of the round
to win players must either steal the
flag from the opposing team or eliminate
all their players with snowballs
yukikazen is very tactic play you don't
have to be strong you must be small and
very quickly and you must have a very
good hand
team's play with regulation-approved
snowballs made by machines
the perfect playing condition is just
below freezing
so the snowballs have enough moisture to
hold their form
they are quite heavy but not too heavy
so they can't be very hot they must be
broken when they hit
the sport is not without its hazards
the most important
is the helmet
if we hit in the head it doesn't hurt
the finished team might have won this
game
but win or lose the battlefields of
yukigasu have the power to unite not
divide
is now in my heart i love yogi custom so
i i like to spread this yogi because i
want that uh kids and adults
they play and say that this is fun and
people liked it
with 7 billion people on earth
it's a wonder that there are still
corners of this planet that remain
untouched
but one man has made it his life's work
to see them no matter what danger the
journey may bring
mike labecky has never been one to shy
away from a challenge
the former national geographic explorer
of the year has completed major
expeditions on all seven continents
he's a modern day explorer who puts his
life on the line to challenge the idea
of what humans are capable of enduring
his goal
to seek out the earth's last truly
untouched places
[Music]
i grew up in california about 30 miles
from yosemite national park the center
of the universe for climbing
my friend's older brother's friend
happened to take us out rock climbing
one day totally random i didn't even
know what rock climbing was
and
it changed my life that day
as soon as i came home from my first day
of climbing i was buying climbing rope
climbing shoes harness climb climb climb
that's all i could think about and that
basically evolved into living in
yosemite climbing el capitan and half
dome and i think oh my gosh i could take
this climbing all over the world
lebecki's passion for adventure has
taken him around the planet to nearly
100 countries
but he's not content with following
traditional routes
his specialty is bagging first ascents
first ascent is basically climbing a
route or going to the top of a mountain
no one's climbed for so truly going into
parts of the planet that no human has
been to before it really takes every
single thing that you have
i mean these aren't just first ascents
these are the most remote most demanding
first descents and climbs on the planet
there is no rescue possibility we're 100
self-reliant
and i'm not seeking danger or death i'm
seeking the ultimate challenge and the
ultimate mystery of what's out there
from the blistering heat of
afghanistan she got hot quick
to the extreme cold of canada the
weather is getting worse and it is cold
up here the climber turned explorer's
trips have taken him through every
climate
but in his expeditions the becky has
learned to love conditions like these
did this incredible trip to a place
called queen modland antarctica
the most remote big wall climbing place
there is on the planet i think it's
technically one of the windiest places
on the planet heavy crazy winds that are
100 120 miles an hour
that is some very real deal environment
to be in you will freeze quick and so
there are these winds called catabatic
winds
they're just hammering and hammering at
all times
they come from the south pole and
they're pushed out towards the north
through different channels around
antarctica
and we happened to be in this sort of
fjord-like valley where the winds were
just you know channeling down and it was
the most challenging environment i've
ever been in
the cool thing about being in an
environment like that with the right
equipment is you start to acclimate into
these conditions you start to get used
to and start to understand how it's
working
up here just near the summit in queen
modland antarctic on a beautiful
sweet wall
you sort of make a friendship with this
environment
i have thousands of maps downstairs and
it's just constant planning and constant
research
there's an incredible amount of physical
demand
carrying 100 pound loads for 80 miles
you know climbing these
big walls enduring all the weather and
the environments looks like a storm is
upon us we're a little bit delirious
cold dehydrated you know one of the
things i have to do is train i have to
be physically fit to have this lifestyle
and one of my favorite ways is to train
with my dogs
i have a mother and daughter dog scree
and glacier and they're my favorite
training partners and we get out in the
mountains literally every single day
that i'm home
and you really have to work hard or you
will suffer out there
being an explorer has a lot of
responsibilities it's not just going out
and climbing exploring it's getting
people excited to care more about the
planet and being able to share these
stories without about remote places or
these remote cultures
with 23 more trips in the works
lebecki is likely to reach his goal of
100 expeditions before long i'm
self-diagnosed with oecd and that's
obsessive expedition climbing disorder
it's my fuel of life i've often thought
about when will i stop going on these
expeditions and it's basically when will
the passion stop
i hope it never does because this is a
passion this is what i love this is what
drives me you gotta live a sweet life
[Music]
[Music]
this is the story of a plant
but not just any plant
it is the story of a plant that long
long ago
once ruled the world a plant that today
is the very last of its kind
it's this plant behind me encephalitis
woody eye e woody eye for short and i've
been looking after it for over 20 years
it was named for british botanist john
medley wood who in 1895 discovered it
growing on a hillside on the coast of
south africa a strange handsome plant
caught his eye and he carefully removed
a small portion of it and had it shipped
all the way to london to hear kew
gardens where it's been for the last 117
years but its history goes much
much
further back
you see encephalitis woody eye is what
is known as a cycad
and sonic heads have been around for 300
million years as the millennium rolled
on cycads flourished providing shade for
triceratops a perch for pterodactyls and
a tasty snack for brontosauruses at one
point during the jurassic cycads made up
20
of all the plants on earth and covered
every corner of the globe
but
the good times couldn't last forever
the dinosaurs went extinct
ice ages came and went
new modern plants like conifers and
fruit trees started pushing cycads out
and the once proud population of e woody
eyes were reduced and reduced and
reduced
until there was possibly only one left
one single solitary e woody eye growing
quietly on a hillside which brings us
right back to john medley wood
at the time he had no way of knowing
just how rare his discovery was
but expedition after expedition in
search of more e woody eye have proved
fruitless you see cycads are diocese
meaning you need separate male and
female plants to create a new one and
this one happens to be a male a true
lonely bachelor if a female mate cannot
be found it really will be the last of
its kind
to this day researchers are still
looking after all
it's a big world
and might just be a chance
in the meantime he'll have me to keep
him company
the oceans occupy over two-thirds of our
planet but they're in trouble
coral reefs are dying at an alarming
rate
and the fish species that rely on these
aquatic environments are suffering
[Music]
so what if the solution
was art
i think what's really interesting about
having a museum underwater now it's not
just
about its artistic value it's also about
biology and its science their living
breathing entities
by putting his sculptures underwater
artist jason decary's tailor has become
the ocean's unlikely hero
his installations are providing new
homes for marine life and his art is
giving the ocean a fighting chance to
thrive
[Music]
i consider myself first and foremost a
sculptor an artist that's my background
in training and i've done a lot of
snorkeling and diving when i was young
we moved around the world as a family we
lived in malaysia and thailand and we
used to explore all the coral reefs
along there
for me
being underwater has always been like
kind of religious experience
i was very much fascinated in working
with the sea using my work for not just
for artistic purposes but also as a tool
for conservation
his big idea
place his eccentric sculptures
underwater so that coral and other sea
creatures can make them home
i started with small projects and i
realized that you know as soon as you
immerse your works into this new
environment
everything completely changes they are
transformed they really take on the
characteristics of the environment
[Music]
i call it a museum for sort of many
different reasons i think
when we put something in a museum we
have a different relationship with it we
want to protect it and we want to
cherish it we want to
conserve it
over the last 10 years jason has opened
three other museums throughout the
caribbean in 2016 he turned his
attention to the atlantic ocean
we are currently here in my studio which
is in lanzarote part of the canary
islands
i'm always looking for the sort of new
challenge the new adventure a new
environment for my work
there's no corals here when i first came
here you know i dived the sights we were
looking at and it really was really
desolate you know just swimming over
sand for quite some time
[Music]
jason will create 300 sculptures as part
of museo atlantico
his new underwater museum
and while his art has the ability to
regenerate marine life his process is
far from simple
finding the site is the most important
thing
we're always looking for areas where
we're not inflicting any any damage on
the existing marine life we try to work
with areas that are completely desolate
my sculptures are based on life models
and so people come to the studio we
actually cover them in a dental solution
make an impression of their bodies and
then with that we actually fill the
molds with a special type of marine
cement and this cement is ph neutral it
doesn't damage the environment anyway
and it actually provides the perfect
habitat for marine life to attach and to
grow
i'll make a certain ledges substrates
that will actually attract sponges
little holes and nooks and crannies that
will attract different species of fish
and crustacean
we then have to transport them to the
site
they're pieces that we've worked hard at
in the studio for for many months they
become very personal to you and then
it's kind of this process of letting go
saying goodbye they're about to start a
new journey
so the sculptures change rapidly once
they're underwater
here in lanzarote we've seen some really
incredible results just after two weeks
there was significant transformations
we've seen a lot of different types of
algae we've seen some sponges adhere to
them
marine life is actually
changing the the surfaces adding patinas
morphing the forms and they make the
whole sort of sculpture become alive
but i wasn't quite expecting how
dramatic they would change and how
beautiful a colonization would actually
look
you can't get a better co-collaborator
than nature
jason's art doesn't just support marine
life and promote ocean health
it attracts tourists which can be a very
powerful tool for raising awareness i
kind of really like the idea of instead
of us always being
apart from natural environments it's
kind of we are nature we are all part of
the same system
by putting my work into these difficult
to access places i hope people have a
better understanding and really realize
what incredible resource our oceans are
and how desperately urgent it is to try
and protect them
[Music]
wayne adams and catherine king don't
live in your typical house
but this is their dream home freedom
cove
a floating island completely off the
grid
it's nearly an hour to the nearest town
tofino british columbia an area known
for its mild summers and wicked winters
but this married couple doesn't mind the
elemental extreme
they embrace it
[Music]
we live in a secluded cove
the only option we have to get here is
by water there are no road accesses
the water is our highway
24 years ago we both knew that we wanted
to live
out in nature
we have carved a piece of the world out
for ourselves we
can live uniquely differently
than anyone else on the planet
if we had to survive on just exactly
what we have here we could
we have our main living house we have
our wood shed
we have four greenhouses i am able to
grow all year round this is a temperate
rainforest climate so we do get snow it
will freeze but it never lasts for long
so all the plants can tolerate that
everything that you see here in our home
is floating
we are tied to shore with lines we are
not anchored
the way wayne has the ropes arranged is
what slows down the impact of the wind
we get hurricane force winds in here in
big storms
it's a narrow entrance into this cove
the wind rockets in and whips around and
changes direction so it can be pretty
fierce
[Music]
everything is done with a hand swan
hammer
no power tools i know every board and
nail by name it's about 500 tons that
i'm flowing
i don't get seasick when i go to town i
get land sick
the thing about living in clockwood
sound on the west coast of vancouver
island it's the richest biomass on earth
so the opportunity to fish for dinner is
big
i just can get in my canoe and paddle
out in 10 minutes i can catch a fish
but when it's windy and too too rough
out there i can lay on the coach or fish
out of the house
[Music]
there's no quick fix
living out here you have to do the work
to get what you want if you want it
it was a great opportunity to actually
move away from the city to see if we
could
prosper out here
now 24 years later we're still doing it
i can't imagine living any other way i
feel completely fulfilled
oh that's good huh
that's really nice
i'm working on it
[Music]
roman lacombe is a man on a mission air
pollution is an environmental issue but
most of all it's a health crisis more
than 5 million people die every year
from pollution related illnesses
roman wants to change that
he has designed a system to help humans
learn more about the air they breathe
and he did it in the most unconventional
way imaginable
using pigeons wearing tiny backpacks i
will never look at pigeons ever again
like it did before
london like many cities has a problem
pollution
it's so bad here
it kills nearly 10 000 citizens a year
the problem about the weather and
pollution is they interact together and
sometimes create episodes of very high
pollution
london weather is notoriously fickle and
pollution levels change with the weather
rains wash off pollutants and winds
sweep them away
roman wanted to make the invisible
visible
to do that he found a way for people to
know when the air is particularly toxic
enter the pigeon air patrol
the pigeon air patrol was this brilliant
crazy idea to fly a flock of pigeons
over the city of london with tiny little
backpacks to measure air pollution
roman outfitted a flock of 10 birds to
fly around london to monitor air quality
in real time
[Music]
they wore special backpacks equipped
with sensors to measure pollutants like
ozone and nitrogen dioxide and they
weren't just ordinary birds they were
highly trained racing pigeons
we worked with brian
expert pigeon fans here who's been very
widely recognized in the field these are
professional pigeons they race they know
how to always home back to their home
base we had an entire patrol of pigeons
cocoa norbert julius
[Music]
when the pigeons took to the sky
the data they collected was instantly
accessible to anyone on the ground
citizens could tweet the pigeon air
patrol and the nearest backpack sensor
would respond with readings from low
to extreme
thanks to this people tuned in to know
when's a good time to go running and
when you can bike without worrying about
pollution or when you should really take
extra care about the air you breathe the
pigeon air patrol was just a starting
point so of course the pigeon air patrol
was not fixing pollution in london but
by bringing attention from everyone
about this topic we make it easier for
citizens to demand change and so we make
it easier for everyone involved to say
there's an issue there we should
recognize it we should address it and
then we can fix it
[Music]
if we can only make more people care
about what they breathe then of course
it becomes easier to collectively
address the issue
and that's why the pigeons are the
heroes of the story and so important
they really care this message that if we
can care more about our environment then
we'll make our health better for
everyone
you